les gens d'honneur et drapeaux français
enveloppant son cercueil
c'est sur l'hymne à la joie que la
dépouille de l'ancien député et maire
d'héricourt jean-pierre michel décédé
dimanche à l'âge de 82 ans est entré en
l'église saint-georges ce jeudi
après-midi les 150 places autorisées
pour cause de coville était évidemment
toutes occupées par son épouse et les
siens par sa famille politique au sens
très large et surtout par les
héricourtois venus dire adieu à leur
ancien maire
quelqu'un qui était qui était brillant
teris matic c'était vraiment quelqu'un
de formidable je suis un peu ému au
niveau national aussi il a beaucoup
compté sa voix à porter
il a défendu les projets qui aujourd'hui
existe
jean-pierre michel aura marqué la
politique comtoise lui le gardois
parachuté à héricourt à la fin des
années 70 par jean pierre chevènement et
en en devenant le maire pendant 21 ans
député puis sénateur
il restera aussi à l'échelle nationale
comme le principal instigateur du pacte
de solidarité civile le pacs en 1999
co écrit avec le député patrick bloche
qui a tenu à être là aujourd'hui c'est
quelqu'un qui aura fait vous savez dans
la vie politique il ya ceux qui sont
plus préoccupés par ce qu'ils sont et
d'autres qui sont plus préoccupés par ce
qu'ils font est bien jean-pierre entrer
dans cette catégorie pour la politique
précisément le diacre jacques duchêne
qui célébrait le match ce jeudi fut
pendant dix ans avant d'embrasser la
fois un adversaire de jean pierre michel
au conseil municipal comme un ultime
clin d'oeil à une carrière faite de
débats et d'amitié de tous bords